mon basset a horreur de m'entendre
chanter dès que je chante il ya quelques
disques qui ne supporte pas et autorise
supporte pas ses mots
le rock'n'roll ça fait peur
le rock'n'roll c'était la violence or
les animaux non le rock'n roll ce pas la
violence est une musique parmi tant
d'autres qui au contraire très agréable
très vivante c'est des gens mal
intentionnés qui ont associé le rock'n
roll à la violence mais je ne crois pas
le lapin violent oui je crois pas que
l'organe reçoit une musique violente
pas du tout il a cinq ans la fin alors
que normalement quand on voulait vendre
les lapins nains ou dire oh là là
maximum non non et demi deux ans grand
maximum vous verrez il ça ne mange
qu'une salade par semaine lui mange au
moins deux salades par jour de carottes
du pain ce très beau lapin il est très
gentil mort un peu aigri fin peut il
toujours affamé et à manger la salade on
veut même pas tiens tu me fait mentir
moi je vois ça va puis voilà ils mangent
la salade
il est boulimique mais il en dit pas à
lui non la joie qui est à sa taille
adulte ligne est en pleine forme ayant
dit pas qu'andy part
comme ça
oui
sans surprise le candidat
pour toute ma vie et que tu restes comme
ça surtout ne convient pas aux papilles
c'est le gros nounours de la famille
souche est très intelligent très
agréable malgré sa grosse heure ce que
beaucoup de gens peuvent penser c'est un
chien pas du tout encombrants peut-être
moins encombrant qu'un petit chien un
chien sensationnel mais le regard
ah ben on voit pas toutes façons il
n'aime pas qu'on lui découvre les yeux
si on lui découvre les yeux il aime bien
qu'on lui remette ses cheveux dessus
enfin ses poils dessus parce qu'il sait
des chiens qui sont très fragiles des
yeux par contre qu'on l'ouïe et l'odorat
merveilleusement bien développé tresseur
l'air triste
intéressant et triste de naissance et là
il ya encore moins de risques quand il
était petit quand il avait deux mois il
avait la même longueur d'oreilles et il
avait les yeux encore plus triste quand
il était tout petit c'était très drôle
parce que à deux mois il se marchaient
sur les oreilles
ce qui il avait une toute petite patte
encore plus petite que celle là déjà
qu'il est assez bas et c'était c'était
très drôle
là c'est sa position favorite un coussin
le lit il dort tout le temps il chasse
les fauteuils et les divans et les
coussins il ne fait jamais rien pour
rien c'est à dire il ne fait pas
d'efforts pour rien c'est à dire par
exemple s'il joue avec un chien et qui
voit un chien qui fait un cercle plutôt
que de lui courir après comme frais les
autres chiens lui va couper le cercle
pour attraper le chien sens en faisant
le moins de courses possible mais il
adore avec tristan n'a jamais eu pour le
moment de rapport sexuel x ça commence à
faire bien parce qu'il est quand même
assez âgées alors un jour on lui a
présenté une très belle dame de sa race
il l'a boudé il n'a jamais voulu il y
joue trop avec un gros chien lui 8
amoureux des grosses chiennes
alors évidemment ça ferait de drôles de
race parce que j'ai des gros chien noir
ou achetés par rapport à lui qui est
tout petit sur pattes
il ya très longtemps
j'aimais pas les chats benjamines pas
que je n'aimais pas maison je ne
souhaitais pas avoir de chats
personnellement et ma femme m'a toujours
dit tu verras c'est des animaux
formidable très indépendant et il faut
freiner la musique aux gens fous
complètement des fois ne piétinent
la platine sur lequel passent les dix
parce qu'elle essaye d'échapper à un
chien qui lui court après pour jouer je
veux dire la musique elle s'en fout
complètement
j'ai connu un chat qui adorent et
georges brassens qui ronronnait qui
venait écouter près du pic à georges
brassens
elles n'auront eux pas tellement porté
sur la butte
dans la main
ce que je veux rentrer chez moi
on
m
il ya des gens qui pensent que je suis
triste dans la vie mais pas du tout je
pense être relativement drôle et du mois
je m'entoure de gens très drôle alors
c'est tout de l'humour mais sauf les
bêtes je veux dire les bêtes c'est par
amour ça ça n'a rien à voir
j'ai peur des voitures c'est tout parce
que malheureusement paris même on marque
beaucoup de voitures et ça c'est le
danger pour les chiens jure eux mêmes
ils suivent
il n'y a pas de problème 5h du mat ya
pas de voitures en rythme et en moyens
pour les promener le meilleur moment 5
ce fou
je suis bien
kabore suffrages
c'est déjà trop
chacun